kevin sire-marin magistrate mans de la
ligue des droits de l'homme bonsoir
madame inscrire merci d'être avec nous
on viens de l'entendre amnesty qui
dénonce des développements qui vont dans
une direction nocifs problématiques et
dangereuses on parle tout de même de la
france le pays des droits de l'homme ce
que vous partagez vous ce sentiment
oui je partage ce sentiment je ne suis
pas la seule il y a également le
rapporteur spécial de l'onu qui a
souligné qu' il y avait une régression
des droits de l'état de droit en france
et aussi la cncdh la commission
nationale pour les droits de l'homme
donc c est un problème en ce sens que la
france est engagée sur un terrain de
diminution des droits des citoyens
depuis un temps assez long depuis vingt
ou trente ans il ya eu trente et une loi
sécuritaire depuis une trentaine
d'années et ces dernières années huit
lois qui ont augmenté les les pouvoirs
de la police diminuent et les
compétences des juges indépendants en
france
est ce qu'on observe aussi et ce qui n'a
peut-être pas été dit c'est que
peut-être une limitation du rôle du
parlement c'est une démocratie la
démocratie française où l'exécutif a de
plus en plus de poids le judiciaire
bien qu'il ya des affaires médiatiques
qui semble indiquer que notamment en
matière économique et financière la
justice joue tout à fait son rôle
désormais mais en même temps il y a
comme le disait montesquieu une
incapacité pour les pouvoirs judiciaires
et pour le parlement d'arrêter le
pouvoir exécutif
quand est ce que disait le pouvoir doit
arrêter le pouvoir c'est ça il doit y
avoir des contre-pouvoirs dans une
démocratie et là ce qu'on observe pardon
c'est notamment avec l'état d'urgence lé
les états d'urgence sanitaire
avant antiterroriste depuis cinq ans on
vraiment libère limitée beaucoup les
libertés individuelles
juste deux départements madame c'était
ma question suivante à quoi attribues
ton cd reelin dénoncée par amnesty
cette liste du comité était peut-être
l'occasion pour les gouvernements de
serrer la vis ou ou à une vraie volonté
politique de le faire c'était
manifestons pas tant que ça finalement
bien écouter ce qui s'est passé c'est
que en fait le lan la volonté n'a pas
été uniquement de ce gouvernement
il y a eu déjà avant beaucoup de lois
antiterroristes et ce qui s'est passé
aussi c'est bien sûr les attentats
absolument gravissime du bataclan de
charlie hebdo
donc il y a eu effectivement une
nécessité de lutter contre le terrorisme
mais est-ce que les moyens qui ont été
choisis étaient les bons moyens
je crois qu amnesty international pense
que non et la ligue des droits de
l'homme c'est exactement la même chose
c'est-à-dire que vous voyez on a permis
beaucoup plus les perquisitions au
domicile et fort des préfets notamment
la limitation du droit de manifester la
limitation également du droit de se
déplacer
le fait de pouvoir assigner à résidence
des personnes par non pas par les juges
mais par des préfets des autorités
exécutives
voilà je crois que les moyens qui ont
été choisis n'était pas n'étaient pas
les bons parce que ça a permis aussi
finalement de réprimer le mouvement
social il faut bien le dire et gilet
jaune et c'est donc
et là on assiste en ce moment à deux
lois qui pose énormément de problèmes
la loi sécurité globale qui s'appelle
autrement désormais qui est en
commission mixte paritaire et qui crée
une nouvelle infraction à troyes ce soir
elle est dangereuse oui elle est drôle
chose pour la liberté de la presse et
pour la liberté d'expression en ce sens
que ça va être maintenant le fait de
divulguer des éléments d'identification
d'un militaire d'un policier
qui va être puni de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement or vous savez qu'il ya
eu des violences policières en france
c'est certain même si de façon générale
la police fait son travail il ya eu des
violences policières et devant la
justice le fait de filmer des violences
policières qui se déroule
c'est la seule manière d'obtenir des
preuves pour établir ces violences
policières et punir les auteurs
donc je trouve que les pénaliser
pénalité les gens qui filme ces
violences policières c'est un problème
la france qui est également épinglé dans
sa gestion des enfants de djihadistes
retenues dans les camps en syrie on
rappelle quand même une notion c'est
aussi l'opinion publique
est-ce que l'exécutif est pris en étau
justement par ses opinions et qui
demandent peut-être de la fermeté sur ce
genre de thématique bien sûr il faut
quand même souligner aussi que la france
dans le conseil de l'europe n'est pas le
pire pays
bien sûr de déclin des droits on a quand
même d'autres pays
bien évidemment qu'ils sont bien pire
puisque je pense à la turquie je pense à
la russie notamment où là on a carrément
le fait d'emprisonner ou d'essayer même
de d'éliminer des opposants politiques
mais la france vous avez raison et prise
un peu en étau entre une opinion
publique dont on dit qu elle voudrait
plus de répression et en même temps vous
savez quand vous parlez avec les gens on
s'aperçoit que quand cette répression
touche des proches
isis ont absolument opposés je pense
notamment à la question des violences
policières vous m'interrogez sur les
enfants de djihadistes je crois que de
nombreux français doivent admettre que
un enfant de 4 ans ou cinq ans enfermé
dans un camp n'est pas un terroriste et
qu'il serait très souhaitable de le
rapatrier en france
autre épingla de la france à son rôle
dans l'exportation des armes paris qui
se place comme
l'un des plus importants exportateurs
d'armes dans le monde parfois vers des
pays qui ne respectent pas justement les
droits de l'homme
doit-on également de changer de
politique sur ce sujet on est d'ailleurs
assez en retard par rapport à certains
voisins européens comme l'allemagne ou
l'italie
bien sûr on est en retard aussi du poilu
judiciaire puisqu'il y aura eu des
condamnations a notamment d'affaires de
corruption et ses alliés à l'exportation
des armes il lié à la vente d'armes mais
la france est tout à fait en rotin et je
crois que là-dessus amnesty
international a beaucoup travaillé sur
ces questions fait des propositions et
il serait tout à fait souhaitable qu il
ya des conditions qui soient mises
notamment au commerce
en ce qui concerne les pays qui violent
systématiquement les droits de l'homme
il serait vraiment souhaitable que la
france arrête de leur vendre des armes
et autres questions abordées par nestier
à la question des migrants en france
il faut également changer les lois là
aussi l'opinion publique à un poids oui
alors on voit que par exemple dans les
écoles
souvent les parents d'élèves sont
extrêmement sensibles au sort des
enfants étrangers des enfants même de
personnes qui sont sans papiers est
souvent les parents d'élèves ont un
mouvement vraiment de grande humanité en
se disant mais ses enfants le droit
d'aller à l'école comme tout le monde
par ailleurs vous savez que la
législation s'agissant d'immigration
s'est durcie ya énormément depuis vingt
ans notamment par exemple séjour
ensemble de rétention est de plus en
plus long lorsque les gens n'ont pas de
papiers la france essaye d'expulser les
personnes lorsqu'elles ont commis
évidemment des actes contraires à
l'ordre au public ce qu'on ne dit pas
assez c'est que c'est extrêmement
difficile puisque beaucoup de ces
personnes lorsqu'elles sont délinquante
et c'est absolument pas du tout le cas
de l'immense majorité des étrangers mais
lorsqu'elles ont commis des actes
délinquants
il est très difficile en fait de les
expulser puisque
souvent exempt déchirer leur part leur
passeport leur pièce d'identité et donc
on ne peut pas en fait les expulser dans
leur pays d'origine et souvent ne
connaît même pas leur pays d'origine
mais c'est vraiment une toute petite
minorité par rapport à l'extrême
majorité des gens qui sont étrangers en
france et il semble que il serait
souhaitable quand même de permettre
beaucoup plus facilement la
naturalisation de personnes qui
souhaitent s'intégrer sur le territoire
français quant à la condition des
étrangers elle est quand même
extrêmement difficile en france lorsque
ils veulent être régularisés merci
greenster marin d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france